welcome back to new rockstars news
everyone today we are talking about
suicide squad
two believe it or not with the big news
that guardians of the galaxy writer
director james gunn has
signed on we'll also talk about uh glass
the new trailer the live-action aladdin
movie trailer some other stuff
and special note everyone this is the
one year anniversary of new rockstars
news
looks like we made it we'd have to pay
for the rights
we've definitely come a long way since
then we changed the name of the show
some of us has changed our names because
of a cease and desist
yeah i just went by um gaga for a bit
and then i just
received a season decision didn't know
she existed um but i just want to say
what a pleasure it's been nerding out
with
some combination of the three of you
once a week for the past year
you guys are my favorites and uh to
celebrate at the end of the show
we're gonna drink that sam hand it over
we can't see it oh
this thing right here all right and if
you can see this can you you might have
to punch in
uh later this is the most elegant most
rare bottle of champagne you can find
that is because it is mountain dew baja
blast you think it's only available at
taco bell and it
is because they have exclusive deal
except we have a bottle of a champagne
version
right here we've been waiting for uh
with the one year mark to crack it
yeah fun fact steve zaragoza gave this
to me on the last day of sourcefed
uh and look where we came now look where
steve is now
no thank you steve so much we couldn't
have done it without you
uh so also a more fun fact i think
it expired 18 months ago cool but we'll
be drinking at the end of show let's see
how we react
it would have been expired on our debut
episode
oh steve give me poison i feel like if
this is like
that's how we get you in as champagne
where are like the gold fleck dorito
chips to go with him
devon next year devon give us mean to
sound ungrateful
all right we'll stick around for the end
of the episode when we'll do that uh and
of course i'm eric voss joining me here
at the table are sam batcher philip
malina and maud garrett hello
welcome back guys and let's uh ten more
years of this
yeah it's the commemorative 2016 bottle
yeah
confirmed it went bad in march 2017.
what are you doing in 2016.
he wasn't born yet let's take a look
and we're back uh let's get started with
our top story this week
okay let's let's talk about this james
gunn joining suicide squad two
it is confirmed that he will be writing
the film uh and that it'll be a
completely fresh take on the franchise
uh take that as you will so far no word
on whether he'll be directing
quick reminder james gunn was let go
from directing guardian directing
guardians of the galaxy vol 3.
uh they will they will use the script
for that movie uh he
uh posted some offensive tweets that he
had deleted
and then um everyone freaked out over it
and and then he got fired
uh so he's a free agent and warner
brothers picked him up interestingly
the original director and writers of
suicide squad two had already finished a
script but
uh it turned out i guess to be pretty
close to the upcoming birds of prey
movies
so maybe yeah they were already looking
for like a new direction to go with it
uh both suicide squad and the guardians
movies feature ragtag ensembles trying
to save the world for one reason or
another they're
you know redemption redemption tales
have a lot of fun with music dirty
dozens
yeah so you can kind of see how this
would be a great fit suicide squad
director david ayer actually gave his
blessing
on twitter and uh dave batista drax
himself once in
what do you guys think yes best news
that could have happened to suicide
squad uh
by far in fact i was a little upset
about it because it feels like a
demotion a little bit where it's like
like maybe if he'd gotten justice league
after uh uh guardians and it'd be like
oh
you know he could fix justice league and
it's kind of a promotion but that said
suicide squad had a lot of potential
and it had some issues and specifically
it was that thing where they like
tried to make it a music video and a
movie at the same time
and who's the only person we know who
did a good job of doing that exact same
thing
james gunn it's a perfect fit i'm super
excited for it now yeah this is he's 100
like the plug that's going to fit in the
sinking ship
but i actually am more excited about
suicide squad now
um when they say he's going to go in a
completely new direction
that's just like the nicest subtlest way
to say nothing like what you saw the
first time
i do wonder though how much he's going
to borrow from his writing styles with
guardians of the galaxy because you know
the foundations are very very similar
when you think about it
um and i kind of am now scared of birds
of prey hmm
yeah what is that because it's very very
similar to what suicide squad two was
going to be yeah how similar you know
like it's
simple enough to scratch it and study
the entire thing yeah
i honestly did batista when he said he
said he was sounded interested i'm like
okay this could be fun like he could be
there's a lot of characters he could be
it sounds interesting but this i am
excited because
i like james gunn this seems like if he
were to correct
suicide squad and what they've done he
seems like a good guy to do it but also
it feels weird it feels like there's no
way i don't know how i could watch this
movie without having like all this weird
baggage that's attached to it now like
there's so there's so much going into
this movie not just with suicide squad
or james gunn it's a big combination of
everything and is wait till the
caskets announced because they're going
in a new direction that's no
confirmation that any of the actors from
suicide squad are coming back
like so uh surely they've signed a deal
maybe marvel robbie
probably will smith but besides that i
mean that's the only people we care
about so actually never mind
probably yeah you know hernandez i hope
they do
go it sounds like he does is looking at
recasting and i wouldn't even i mean as
much as i like margot robbie in the
movie i wouldn't mind if he does a
completely fresh take completely new
actors taking over every role really
because as good as i think
margot robbie was in that role they i
didn't see a lot of chemistry between
cast members in that movie she did sign
on for birds of prey and her movie and
the joker harley movie and
probably like recast them all yeah but
no i i agree with you
with what you're saying where it's like
the excitement of a new version
but actually uh i used to feel that way
until thor ragnarok
honestly was like sure you can totally
remake the same person and the actor
wants to flex different muscles yeah so
she could do a whole different version
not on with or without letter without
you don't need to do that don't do that
i don't think the joker needs to be in
the story at all like a suicide squad
it's not
yeah i think it'd be better for you to
put them in honestly um one
quick thing just just a concern i don't
know if you guys want to discuss it but
just so the one thing that suddenly
reminded me of is a little bit of joss
whedon
taking over justice league where it's
like the comedic director is going to
come in and
you know make it fun and lively and
taking over for the more
dark serious director and then it's like
okay well that didn't work
well that's what a lot of people are
saying right they're like oh it's it's
uh
warner brothers once again trying to say
hey marvel we got your guy and we're
gonna
like give him if you want him back
you've got to give us the idea of how to
make a good movie
yeah please uh yeah but i do like the
movie
it's very different situations right
like in zack snyder's case he had to
take like
basically family leave and then josh
sweden had to take over a movie that
had mostly been shot right as opposed to
starting from square one
which is a new script so much better
actually yeah that's the way it should
be yeah
uh rfp though uh todd stashwick uh david
barkatz the people who have previously
had written the script already and
uh also probably gavin o'connor the
director is probably out too as my guess
is yeah i mean in the writer's case i
assume they got paid
uh to do sure yeah they'll hopefully get
more work from it
um now just to throw in a bit of drama
batman news.com pointed out that james
gunn
has gone after jared leto in the past
and uh you know
our favorite joker right uh in 2012
gunn tweeted driving home from vegas
trading stories about what a dick jared
leto is
and then just a few months ago he joined
dylan sprouse and slamming the actor for
going after young girls again on twitter
uh any chance you guys think this fresh
take might uh
have a different actor or would dc want
to avoid bringing up this drama on
twitter
uh and yeah well they're not gonna put
in the commercials
from the two people who ate each other i
don't think so i
probably i you won't see any joker yeah
definitely not jared that's my guess
especially honestly it's over saturated
right immediately because we have other
yeah he does a good job with d-listers
with characters that you don't know so
just use some characters that you don't
know
easy peasy fill it out do another el
diablo no one knew who that was and
he was fine i didn't mind his story i
didn't mind it either but like pick
characters like that's haunting
and i i think um as much as we like to
talk about i think most people who go
watch these movies are not aware of like
the drama the personal drama going on
with the actors and the directors
careers and things like that and that's
my
whole thing when it comes to james gunn
i think everything has been overblown
with this yeah and i think disney might
have overreacted a bit because i think
if they just let it blow over
people will forget that james
delete your feed delete your timeline
delete everything and never tweet again
brave new world that we live in uh but
let's move on to our trivia question
this week right
the blue buckets
what did i say he just woke up
did i miss a happy halloween okay here's
our question this seems like a toughy
uh aside from award shows suicide squad
star margot robbie and garadians of the
galaxy star chris pratt
have two shared credits name at least
one
and looks like all of our answers are in
the
famous blue bucket here uh as always
the winner of our trivia question we'll
get to our reader goodbyes the loser
will have to join the gif of shame club
i think we're all members of it now yeah
yeah shane oh shane
you guys love it uh but let's move on to
some other news sam what did you see
this week
and thank you all last night i was able
to take a little peep
at a teaser the very first teaser for
the next live-action disney movie
aladdin and i'm gonna do one of my
signature little baby breakdowns
starting with this first image let's
take a little peek on the television uh
let's take a look oh in the background
you'll notice agrabah that's the
setting that is sand that's real cgi
sand one of the benefits of a live
action aladdin movie buckle up kids
this breakdown's about to get crazy but
now you can see agrabah in the
background
and immediately kind of get a little
feel for that this movie doesn't feel as
magical as the animated movie because as
soon as like agrabah shows up in the
animated movie
it seems like this magical oasis and
then this it's like it's a city
little baby hot takes breakdown i've
definitely seen this from attack of the
clones by the way guys
like same settings they saved a lot of
money since they bought star wars yeah
uh
eric said that finn should pop up right
from the bottom
horns over sand that is star wars
just see race like sliding down from uh
the buildings look like naboo
hmm interesting
let's go to our next image here we'll
see one of our iconic characters
from the aladdin tale iago he actually
looks pretty good
he is a parrot he's it's great still
he's flying he's flying over there in
the corner
we know he's voicing him uh as of right
now of me talking no
take our quick guesses who has the most
annoying voice in comedy john
oh it is no no he's doing zazu oh yeah
yeah who's the last kathy griffin
it might be he's not working too much
right now he might come back i just
don't hear anyone else except him
and did you guys see that gorgeous um
documentary about the
the group that gets together there's
about a guy who has um autism and he can
only really learn through disney movies
and he has a disney club and god
like but they were eating it up because
it was it was
jazz man
[Laughter]
you know it's very sweet it's very very
sweet
what do you mean i'm free let's take a
look at the next image here
uh right up the bat you see in the front
of the cave of wonders
it's yours i liked this uh i liked it
but uh yeah where it's not gonna be
talking it's just gonna be a bane voice
coming out a hole in the mountain shout
out to oleo
is that a lion now how fun
but the main reason i wanted to point
this out is we get our first look at our
main villain for the movie can you guess
who it is of course
it's jafar yeah
[Laughter]
it shouldn't be a line because lions and
tigers though definitely in different
areas of the world
oh my flying you wouldn't be able to
trust a word it says
fart sound that was
brilliant
no this is a great one jafari is over
there let's go to the next image
it's right there in the front you almost
missed the man that's the last image
anyways it's of aladdin reaching for the
for genie's lamp and i like genie's lamp
i like the way that they brought it to
life but i also want to mention you can
see in the cave of wonders it's filled
with the treasure they're all familiar
with
of course aladdin doesn't even grab one
thing out of that room except for the
lamp which i would have at least grabbed
like five coins but that's me
right on the edge
but who's that standing down there next
to him uh that would be a rock
yeah it's a rock that is a rock dwayne
johnson
it's like it could be a little statue
yeah but this it's this scene famously
it's him by himself and this we're going
to get the first introduction of
him with genie hopefully we'll get a
great song from wilson stripes in
that era i have a it looks like a
baseball shirt i'm very curious
i'm very curious to see how aladdin's
ghost babe from the animated series
comes
the whole production value is very
interesting because to me this screams
aladdin
on ice yeah yeah yeah
the california defense show yeah i saw
that one no
it's weird because there i like the the
details that they put into the genie's
lamp i think that's beautiful
and i do like his costume and i like all
the actors that they have on board for
this movie but a lot of the
visuals that made it really cool to
watch as a kid brought to life
at least the way that guy rich and his
team have chosen to bring this to life
it's a it's a little disappointing but
again
this is the teaser we got like fifteen
seconds
things could change hey in venom they
did they redid all the audio so they
said symbiote right but so anything
could happen
yeah yes they did actually not commit to
their error
and like try to convince everyone else
that it was wrong the whole time
yeah they said simba oates right yeah
it's a gif yeah
great these are great hater baby today i
know i'm being negative
i am excited for this movie like i said
and will i want to see what will smith
does with the genie role and i think
that's the reason why most people would
actually want to see this movie yeah
because and also
there's a weird combination people who
will see this movie it's like people who
are die hard disney fans
and then the other people are like what
could they possibly do with this movie
like what could
curiosity yeah like how could you make
genie like come to life in this movie
but
that's me i'm excited blue will smith
uh all right guys this week we got a
trailer for m night shyamalan's glass
it's the sequel to unbreakable and split
and we saw the first trailer at comic
con i did a breakdown of it go check
that out here i thought we'd do just a
quick
it'll widdle baby breakdown of the new
details like cotton trailer that's right
we
got another baby breakdown coming right
out yeah customary spoiler warning
in case we get too good at predicting
stuff some people were saying like this
trailer predicted too much but all
trailers predict
stuff so that's an invalid complaint
when
here we go uh well first uh let's talk
about bruce willis character
this is uh david dunn he has the powers
of super durability and strength he can
um bench press paint cans
along with the ability to touch people's
hands and he can see the bad things
they've done
oh there's more to it you can't touch
people's hands and they can bench press
paint cans
that's what i remember what if the paint
came out
and then um the poster actually revealed
this hero's name as the overseer
and i love that name because i just
think this passive hero
who's like eating a big sandwich
watching his friends moving firm
for sure like i'm overseeing i don't
need to help out
you're the strongest of us david and
[Laughter]
uh now we do get a subtle knot of this
power when he when david asked dr
ellie's staple on the trailer that's
sarah paulson's character
uh so you're not gonna shake my hand and
let me walk out of here
and then you know she kind of points i'm
like ah nice try he wants to shake her
hand to see what horrible stuff
she did which i'm kind of curious what
horrible stuff she did because there is
a theory
that dr staple may have powers herself
maybe like telepathy
that could be how she was able to find
and imprison all these super powered
individuals and and keep them in check
and she knows
what their vulnerabilities are and
always like the bigger
biggest counterpart to someone who has
incredible strength is to get them with
the minds
juggernaut where's that helmet um now uh
we also learned how dr staple controls
kevin crum that's james mcavoy's
character
uh he has 24 split personalities
including the super strong
beast uh flash bulbs that switch his
personalities they flash
and they flash uh kind of like an
old-school tv remote that only goes up
or down in one direction like nope we
got to cycle through
oh god mom's walking in the room and
then uh you can actually see these flash
bulbs in his room
but you can also see them behind dr
staple in the community room so like you
can kind of see them she brings them
everywhere she goes to control them and
keep them
but also to try to like trigger and see
which uh
like she can read his mind to be like oh
i'm not talking to the right personality
right now
i'm very curious to see very sadistic
interesting
um i think most interestingly we learned
more about elijah price's motive in this
movie this is same oil jackson as mr
glass
uh he's a bittle brown comic book
obsessed criminal mastermind brittle
bone
brittle boned um they call him mr glass
bone
we hear his voice over telling kevin i
need your abilities to get us all out of
here to show the world we exist and he
tells david
i found someone who require your full
potential you shouldn't hide in the
shadows
so you kind of see what his plan is here
it sounds like he's kind of got this
magneto from x-men personnel maybe even
killmonger like if our advancement makes
us superior why should we
hide and if you remember in unbreakable
mr glass orchestrated several terrorist
disasters he was hoping to find a hero
and like bring him out of the shadows it
sounds like he's continuing with that
plan with the beast like unleashing a
super villain on the world
to force the hero the overseer to like
respond and rise bruce willis is here
i'm pretty sure he would be like
yeah don't do that again making fun of
him uh real quick
his powers is brittle bone disease right
chalk bones and smart
and he's but like he's like i know that
they say that this is the smarts but
in in the original movie like he wasn't
insanely smart
he was extremely cunning no he does but
by accident by
or by elijah choosing to show who he
actually is
yeah it's just i feel like they're like
a little bit on this character i'm
really curious how they're gonna amp up
the
the super villain on this element
because yeah if he's if he's like we're
superior race of
oh uh we're superior
like he he's the polar opposite of david
dunn and that like he is super
vulnerable but i think
uh the way a night shyamalan kind of
crafted this cinematic universe which he
didn't imagine a venus in my universe at
the first
was just like how can i ground that so
if someone had to spend all their
childhood in a wheelchair
how would his mind have responded to
that many people
and their little childhoods in
wheelchairs and don't turn into riddles
but what i like about this one is that
we have like a hero or anti-hero villain
whatever way you want to call like
how you want to call them but with all
the marvel and dc we've seen them be so
super and so holier than thou
and you know they're almost perfect and
striving for that but here we see real
flaws
like you know we see you know he's
breakable with his character you see
the fact that bruce willis is was he he
said 60 what
yeah he's very old you know and james
mcavoy like one character
one of his personalities can get you
through it but 23 one of them's like a
kid
you know yeah so like there's so many
sort of vulnerabilities and weaknesses
here for them to succeed
i think that's cool yeah yeah and i i
think this is one of the few times you
see
a villain's real motive already in the
trailer like i know what his goal is and
i think it's an interesting goal like
at the end of unbreakable it's
fascinating that reveal of what mr glass
had done and how dastardly and
horrible these killings were uh so but i
also just like the way that this movie
appears to be embracing mr glass's mania
for comic book tropes like it's almost
like a
meta deconstruction of the of this whole
idea he's got that mg
mr glass sigil on his it looks like an
ascot or collar or whatever that is i
thought it was a necklace but it's just
like on
it uh and if you look at the color
palette of these trailers in this
footage it's amazing so
there's like a purple versus green color
palette with purple being the color of
mr glass and green being the color of
david dunn it was there in very muted
terms what's the sam jackson's color
ready it's the color that he requested
that jedi have a lightsaber
specifically it's a good coat yeah it's
so and you can see throughout the
trailer there's like
imagery that's like oh if it's green
here this is like a heroic moment if
it's
purple this is a villainous moment and
you uh see that with the slow motion
shot in the trailer of david unfurling
his green raincoat
um and it kind of looks like a superhero
cape the way it works
uh so there's just some really great
imagery and also if you just listen to
it one last little thing you can hear
remix versions of
uh james newton-howard's score for
unbreakable 18 years ago it's a new
composer but this is just one of the
many ways that glass will
really be a true spiritual ancestor of
uh the unbreakable film they're even
bringing back the same actors they're
bringing back the kid who played
bruce willis's son yeah and anna taylor
joy's coming back
um i like there was a uh one thing you m
you mentioned
in uh in kevin's cell you have the
lights in
david's cell there's sprinklers all over
because water is his
vulnerability so it's like oh also like
wow that is super
like that's super messed up that's like
it's not even like that's not
i don't know what it does to him like
showers are fine but like
i it it's super confusing like and
immediately you start getting like vibes
that if
uh the main therapist is like if she
does have abilities i'm like
you would hope in this movie that you'd
get a balance that's what the first
movie kind of showed that
there's a good person and there's a bad
person with split you have any taylor
joy kind of being the
hero mainly just outliving everybody
else uh in this movie you would kind of
hope that there would be
another good person that would pop out
of this but she is
the way she's setting all this up it
doesn't seem like she's a great
individual so you're thinking she's like
maybe like nurse ratchet
kind of like cookies yeah yeah it brings
out the worst in everyone you can
torture them and yeah yeah destroy them
she's literally gonna break i mean she's
she's um putting she these people have
powers and she's in power over them as
long as they stay there it's
like a psychological thing i think ana
taylor joe is the hero necessarily i
think it was the
out of in the movie split five of the
personalities that were confused that
sided with the beast that you are
they're the only ones that you saw so
there's a bunch that you haven't seen so
i guess that's
gonna be this new and this mary reynolds
one is the new one i like the little
detail of like and i point this out in
the last trailer breakdown he still has
the scar from the shotgun blast
from taylor choice so they're bringing
back like all there's a lot of attention
to detail here that
man those traps he gets when he becomes
the beast and his traps like go to his
ears
what about suddenly and in this yeah he
has a 30-pack yeah
they put their veins in the floor 24
personalities but tatiana maslany's like
24. yeah i only had like seven
yeah that was an awesome black reference
um well let us know what you think about
this trailer
in the comments below and yeah once
again go check out our the trailer
breakdown we did from the one from comic
con there's a lot of interesting details
going on and
this movie comes out uh january 18th uh
so we're already gonna have some big
more hype after seeing this trailer now
or less hype more
more hype it's more so it has a clear
like i have a clear idea of what this
movie's gonna be and uh
something that the neither of the two
previous films had was straight up
uh uh antagonist action on super powered
levels and this seemed like there's a
lot of fight scenes like straight up and
i'm just curious how he's gonna direct
those yeah
i've seen m knight do action before and
avatar so there's that no don't know
don't you
it happened it did not it did alternate
no idea what you're talking about
i paid for a movie ticket it happened oh
i didn't i uh take them away boys
watched it on a plane yeah but uh let's
move on to some other news that uh we
heard from this week mod
that's right i got some other news for
you we got uh mark ruffalo can't shut
his mouth he went on the tonight show
and supposedly he said the avengers 4
title
oh that's like a live audience i'm
pretty sure during that
so what they had to do was bleep it out
and then of course people that actually
know how to figure out technology
managed to sort of
undo the bleep and they think they
believe what the actual title could be
so it's it could be avengers
annihilation
or avengers the last avenger i prefer
annihilation i think that that's an
easier one to say because avengers the
last avenger
that's just a you just saying it twice a
lot of avengers anyway the whole thing
could be a huge hoax you know playing on
the fact that mark ruffalo
that's the one i'm mostly describing by
where they like plan to do this
so it's kind of like building up some
fun marketing and hype for it all
right i hope it's the bleep sounds
yeah it's just the noise of the heart
monitor on it oh
that's it oh too soon for every person
has ever known
anyone oh no i went for the anyway
hey let's come back to in our news yeah
um
we let we kind of because it is new
rocks does dig a little bit into these
two
uh potentials and the whole um
annihilation could be the fact that
wanda uh said to vision i looked into
your head and i saw annihilation so that
could talk about
age of ultron age of ultron that was a
while ago and then
uh in the first captain america movie uh
it was called captain america the first
avenger and that kind of like pioneered
the whole thing so it's a nice little
closing chapter perhaps
uh that's all yeah yeah it sounds like a
bit that they did that'd be crazy
there's no way disney would give that to
a fox or a nbc show here's the thing the
the these shows cut around stuff all the
time and the fact that they would
include it on the
show is like a little suspect yeah yeah
nda's for days uh next black panther two
we got the sequel happening ryan coogler
is officially riding in direction
big fan of that one ryan uh giggler has
to not
place dodgy value though because he's
obsessed with it as i got the exclusive
in my interview on geek row and it went
on
love started valley which is literally
like a sort of pixelated cute game that
young girls play to farm
and i know that's just one of them and
then marvel's commissioned a dark
avengers script
yeah that's in the works it doesn't
necessarily mean it's gonna be a movie
but it's something that they're
entertaining i'm paying for a script i
mean something
yeah and then maybe you know a team will
ride it and then james gunn will come
along
yeah also we've got a first look at ruby
rose's bat woman what do we all think
that's great interesting hair i mean
it's it's super
accurate yeah to the comics to the point
where i almost felt like it could have
been anybody like doesn't necessarily
feel like
a ruby rose version i actually thought
they were going to like
incorporate kind of her hairstyle a
little bit more into the look
uh but we can all do our own takes on it
because we're doing another new
rockstars contest
for costumes i should have said costume
first contest for costumes
i hate alliteration and i always
separate it whenever i can
a contest for which to choose the
bestest of the costumes
uh so we did one last year we can uh
potentially show
a picture at some point if someone gets
out to devin uh but
uh what we're also gonna do is that you
guys can send us in costumes but here's
the uh catch uh we're not doing just any
old costume you can't just use the one
you've used 10 years in a row eric
uh osmosis jokes
we got to do mashup costumes this year
so take one thing and take another and
mash them together and that's your
costume that's gonna be our costumes
that we do here on the show
that'll be on the uh october 26 episode
of the show
so you have to send in your submissions
to our twitter our instagram any of our
accounts
by october 24th and we're gonna pick the
top five and feature those on our
instagram
and the number one we're gonna put right
up here and we're gonna worship you
uh so make sure to send us submissions
in at new rockstars on most things that
matter
uh mashup costume osmosis and jones are
not two different things that you can
put together
i guess they're just one amazing thing
what else we got yeah last bit of news
uh tom hardy apparently had a meltdown
over the venom script at one point
during filming and he actually walked
off the set yeah he went full
diva yeah ah and considering the fact
that his favorite 40 minutes of the
movie were
cut from the film um this isn't actually
looking good for a venom sequel because
no one disrespects tom hardy like that
he's been kind of a grouch in like
interviews and in life
this movie made a lot of money but i
doesn't mean that he's going to show up
in the city what cost
yeah yeah i'd go back
[Laughter]
we've done some venom videos on the
channel and go check them out but we got
another really fun venom
video coming out oh yeah check that out
soon come in
but now we're gonna do uh my favorite
i'm gonna do this one guys oh man i
messed it up uh
the new rockstars lightning round
and as uh we've done uh whenever i hold
these cards we're doing it as
actual lightning so that means you got
to get you have no time to think you
just gotta
shout out your answer and there's a
bunch of them are we ready i don't care
eric
uh at job manava eric i really enjoyed
your breakdown of the batman trilogy
what other old movies would you want to
break down the old ones
stanley kubrick's the shining stanley
kubrick's 2001 space odyssey
all right sam ah at jeffrey carter do
you think there are restrooms in
atlantis or is everyone just letting it
go in the water all the time
that's like an option the way you do it
uh at uh
nomad at kenzie hagendorn uh if
you were stuck in any cinematic universe
which one would you least
like to be stuck in ah the first thing
that came to mind was the fire
swamp from princess bride the princess
bride cinematic universe uh philip
bianco bozio uh burgers pizza or
burritos burritos because i'm a
stereotype
uh sam at b aquaman oh i hit something
really hard over there
oh i know what is the one piece of pop
culture
comic movie video game etc that you want
to see a film or tv adaptation of
uh plastic man the correct answer was
saga
uh yeah me uh this is really sam
sam uh top three horror movies i should
watch on halloween
uh it follows um the original halloween
and the the new halloween actually i'm
really excited to see it yeah yeah sure
uh eric at the slr test uh
ever noticed that in thor ragnarok the
fake infinity gauntlet was for the right
hand
also that place settings are flat as if
they were like for stores
cut in half stones cut in half i need
answers
about place settings i can't tell you
about flat place study i have no idea
what that is
i mean it's a joke right
yeah it was owen's halloween costume
until yeah
she said fake lightning round
answers uh don't really satisfy
complicated questions um
hp how do you like your coffee and i
just said
like i like me uh flat white yeah we're
here
no yeah the flat white is a it's a like
a latte with more milk
oh i didn't know that that's great it
sounds delicious yes
sure uh we're almost done because we're
gonna go real fast now eric kevin cyto
seven who do you think is going to be
the main composer for star wars after
john williams
retires after episode nine aquino duh uh
mod at oliver
morris19 should they take a break from
star wars filming after episode nine yes
okay uh philip uh at bruce gamefreak who
would you want to play spider-man in the
sony universe
like a different spider-man in the same
universe uh let's go with
uh toby mcguire thanks bruce sam uh at
ali manriquez what is your most
embarrassing guilty pleasure
oh i know lightning smallville say it
is
we're gonna move on to our trivia
question that we asked earlier
oh we have the answer ready to go we're
gonna see how close we all were
and how far others were and uh
there we go okay so just to remind you
guys of what the question was and what
the stakes are
uh first we got our gift of shame you
know how this works
hold on we got to write two questions
required to answer at least one second
one i had to make a choice no no no get
out of here
okay so the question good movie though
one of my all-time favorites
aside from award shows suicide squad
star margot robbie and guardians of the
galaxy star chris pratt
have two shared credits name at least
one of them uh
they name at least one of them what do
you think at least at least means at the
low end
[Laughter]
blonde all right i think i got that's
also my favorite kind of coffee
i think i got it all right so what did
uh mod wrote about time but she meant to
also say benjamin button what did you
say peter rabbit
peter wrap peter abbott and about time
um valentine's one of my all-time
favorite movies philip says
an animated film and a movie with a
two-word title
that's the way i'm putting it i'm
putting out there
no no no i'm about time
and an animated movie peter so we're
basically the same
uh sam uh row wanted
and a magnificent seven that's what i
wanted
yeah yeah that's all i don't remember
wanted at all
it's a kirby
eric thinks the wolf of wall street and
national lampoon's van wilder man wilder
is chris
is margot robbie in that is any big
actor besides ryan reynolds is in that
chris pratt was in some 2000s comments
everywhere he played like a bully frat
dude chris
evans maybe that might have been chris
evans
what's the correct answer oh yeah argo
robbie's in this the correct answer is
lego movie two
which is not out yet in an episode of
jimmy kimmel live those are their two
credits that they shared together
lego movie and jimmy kimmel
a
oh that's fair all right yeah i said two
answers
okay since none of us were remotely
close enough to the right answer
uh where this is what we're gonna do uh
the four of us will do the gift of shame
together we'll draw something
we'll do it all in front of the blue
screen and shame it ourselves and the
person
reading the goodbyes will be our trusty
editor
devin uh cleary uh he's just a hand um
but he's going to do her goodbyes he's
our post-production dude and he's
amazing
um so yeah but before we do that
um let's open up this bad boy and have a
toast yeah
dude every time there's something that's
a trajectory or could shoot at anyone
you hit a woman
i'll say every time it's fun but that's
not what
uh but actually real quick i do want to
say legitimately we started this show
a year ago and we legitimately were like
we should cancel this like a week later
uh and instead we did 52 weeks of it
roughly and i think we should all be
very proud of that
look how far we've come
[Music]
look how far we've come uh let's see
where we came from before
uh if you just want to see a little clip
of what this show used to be like uh you
can't show the title because we got a
cease and desist on that title
1050. no mine was closer to yours was
ten thousand fifteen minus ten thousand
ten thousand
a thousand minus a thousand minus three
thousand seven hundred and seventy
yeah the real answer is
2019. wow
which is in two years time for those
idiots i don't know anything being
young yeah such a little baby yeah
uh well how are we doing over there with
the uh the expired
um don't aim it at me
three two one
did one of those like uh bullet pinging
things around the uh
around the room here that's how off it
is that's a carbonated that's
our neighbors i stand by wanting to have
done it right here
guns don't kill me champagne does okay
well while we get this support here yeah
you guys did
i want to do a special um gift for all
you guys
because it means so much to me and
because the one year anniversary gift in
culture is something paper
and culture i got you each this
wow oh is it literally uh endless paper
endless possibilities
it's paper uh eric this is the only
gift uh in 15 years of knowing each
other that you've already got something
paper and i got you paper and you can
make anything with it you can make uh
friends uh
let's oh do we already have these oh
here we go
did you already sip some of this nope
okay remember this is this is a weird
way to end friday
18 months uh also as we uh
slowly get to give him did you just
drink it no okay
yeah all right uh to at least uh 18 more
months
you shook it up a little bit to get the
bubbles in there yeah
uh cheers guys yeah i'm proud of all of
you
may all our dreams and all your dreams
come true to five more years there you
go
you're my new rock star
well i quit i quit oh
oh i'm not i'm not here for these burps
oh my god
i'm not i'm not feeling those okay
i drank it and then half of it came back
up straight away that is so
tight oh my god
why would you drink more i had the
baby sip you can't even swallow it
you'll get it
oh is it because you're wearing it you
didn't even have anything sick
it's a good thing we've got all this
paper to clean it up eric make sure i
need to see you drink something i did
take a sip i know i
no i'm not all right derek drink some
drinks up dude
shame shame shame oh are you kidding me
are you kidding me i drink half like
glass
oh gosh look it looks like the green
screen stop
man drinking it all right
i'm so used to it being the mug let's do
the gift of shame
you guys are so gross oh yeah all right
okay so the uh
the gif of shame the thing that we have
to do is you've lost your phone
repeatedly pat your clothes looking for
it and look around confused
got it devon get over here uh you got to
drink some of this if you want to do
goodbyes
[Music]
all right i just want to thank you guys
so much for watching this
week's episode of new rockstars news i
want to thank our host
sam basher all the way on the left side
at sam
basher maud's patting me for some reason
eric voss
at ea vos philip molina
fimo and maud garrett at mod garrett
make sure you subscribe to our channel
keep watching new rockstars news and
i don't know where my phone is either
did you guys see my phone you got phone
he's got phone oh i'll see you soon
[Music]
don't drink old soda
[Music]
you